cannibalism is a dark side of humanity
we often don't dip into you and I were
on tour together how long would we have
to go
without food or before you think I might
eat Tom you know the human body can go
like over 30 days without food we need
we need to have water within three or
four so I would probably say we'd have
to do about a month-long tour and then
Daddy would uh start to get the
grumblings and uh
yeah you'd start looking pretty good
would you be sneaky about it and just
start eating me or would you ask
permission what I'd probably do is you
know tap on your door lightly with my
hotel Key the way the chambermaids do
and I I just ask you in your kind of
sleep drizzle would you mind if I what
are you doing here I had an ass cheek
would you mind if I ate a leg would you
mind so you would ask I would